اليوم 98 من الحرب تدخل المنطقه الوسطى
بقوه في مركز اهداف او في بنك اهداف
القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تحاول
بكل الطرق الضغط على منطقه دير البلح في
المنطقه الوسطى تقصف محيط دير البلح تقصف
الجهه الغربيه من دير البلح وتضغط من
الجهه الشرقيه والشماليه الشرقيه على دير
البلح اذا ما دخلنا مباشره الى المنطقه
الوسطى منطقه دير البلح اليوم كان هناك
تحركات لافته للقوات الاسرائيليه المتوغلة
كيلومتر بطبيعه الحال قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تتمركز الان عند هذه النقطه
وتتمركز ايضا عند هذه النقطه في مقابل
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ايضا مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى لا يبعد عن قوات الاحتلال اقل من
كيلومتر كما نشاهد في الصوره اذا قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الان وصلت الى هذه
النقطه قادمه من الجهه الشماليه من بلده
من قريه المصدر ومنطقه المغازي التي كانت
موجوده فيها بطبيعه الحال والتي تعرضت
لقصف عنيف خلال الساعات القليله وال
الايام القليله الماضيه يذكر بان القوات
الاسرائيليه انسحبت من المنطقه الجنوبيه
لدير البلح بين دير البلح وخان يونس منطقه
ابو هولي ومنطقه شمال القراره وحتى وصولا
الى شارع صلاح الدين كل هذه المناطق
انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بعد
ان تمركزت فيها لفتره طويله واستهدفت
القراره في المنطقه الشماليه من خانيونس
لتضغط على مدينه خانيونس من الجهه
الشماليه الشرقيه ولكنها بشكل مفاجئ
انسحبت من كل هذه المناطق التي نشاهدها
على الشاشه من ابو هولي منطقه المطاحن
والقرار وصولا الى السياج الفاصل هي الان
عند السياج الفاصل شرقي قطاع غزه اين
نتحدث عن جنوب شرق دير البلح شمال شرق
مدينه خان يونس انسحابات وتقدمات اعاده
تمحور القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
المنطقه الوسطى تستهدف دير البلح ويبدو ان
هناك سيكون دخول باتجاه دير البلح لانها
تستهدف المنطقه الغربيه تستهدف بقصف عنيف
دير البلح خلال الساعات القليله الماضيه
منطقه البريج ايضا في المنطقه الوسطى التي
لا تبعد كثيرا عن دير عن دير البلح تستهدف
بقصف عنيف قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت
قد دخلت الى البريج من الجهه الشرقيه ومن
الجهه الشماليه وكنا قد شاهدنا في المقابل
عمليات مقاوم من المسافه صفر في منطقه
البريج وفي البريج تم تفجير او انفجار
الشاحنه المليئه بالمتفجرات والتي ادت الى
مقتل سته جنود واصابه 30 اخرين في منطقه
البريج اذا المنطقه الوسطى حتى هذه اللحظه
تشهد ضغطا كبيرا من قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي تضغط على الدير البلح من
الجهه الشماليه لكن كان هناك امران
اساسيان اليوم الامر الاول في المنطقه
الشماليه وهو مقطع الفيديو الذي نشرته
سرايا القدس قبل قليل والذي تحدث عن
استهداف دقيق ومحدد لاليات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في المنطقه الجنوبيه الشرقيه
من مدينه غزه نعلم ان مدينه غزه تمت هناك
انسحابات كبيره منها انسحابات من المنطقه
الشرقيه من الشجاعيه انسحاب شبه كامل
تقريبا اليات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تتمركز
الان عند السياج الفاصل او داخل السياج
الفاصل بضع مئات من الامتار اي انها
انسحبت من منطقه الشجاعيه انسحبت من منطقه
حيي التفاح والدرج انسحبت من الشيخ رضوان
انسحبت من المنطقه الغربيه القاطع الغربي
الصبره والرمال وتل الهواء والان هي
متمركزه في الاطراف عند العطاطه اطراف بيت
لاهيه في المنطقه الشماليه العطاطه في
المنطقه الشماليه الغربيه ايضا تتمركز
قوات الاحتلال في هذه نقطه تتمركز قوات
الاحتلال ايضا في اطراف بيت حنون ولكن
مقطع الفيديو الذي تحدثت عنه سرايا القدس
يتمركز بدرجه اساسيه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه لمدينه غزه اي اننا نتحدث عن
منطقه الزيتون التي تشهد لا تزال قتالا
عنيفا المسافه صفر بين قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والمقاومه الفلسطينيه في
القاطع الجنوبي من مدينه غزه ه